sex
now that I have your attention what
we'll actually be talking about in this
video is
the history of sex in video games
yeah I wasn't
kidding about the sex thing even though
sex is Perfectly Natural we today seem
to have a much more puritanical view of
it when it comes to it appearing in our
media especially in comparison to how we
talk about violence like any human
interaction sex is much more complicated
than hitting X for sex so I want to open
up a conversation about sex in video
games to discuss the ins and outs as it
were and because I'm immature I'm going
to make a lot of innuendos like that one
while we do it
I was like that one that I just did
there
yeah there's going to be a lot of that
so let's dive into a brief three so
hopefully not too free
history of sex and gaming
sex has been around gaming since the
start of the medium because if human
beings are going to create something
we're going to find a way to put the old
bedroom Rodeo into it wow I really can't
say
huh well finding YouTube friendly ways
to say will be a lot of fun in this
video Let's just say for now we're
talking about the old pixel pushing one
of the first and most prominent games to
feature sex was 1981's text-based
Adventure soft porn adventure for the
Apple II in the game you play as a down
on his luck party animal trying to win
the affection of several women and while
that sounds like fun the game wasn't
great in its depiction of women with the
game featuring things like long
descriptions of how tight a girl's butt
looked in jeans or lines like she's
taking a large sausage-shaped object and
looking at it longingly as if women get
simply hypnotized by looking at a
sausage-shaped object
soft porn Adventure sold 50 000 copies
an absurd amount considering the Apple
II's install base was only around 200
000. sex soon came to the Atari 2600
which makes sense because I mean have
you seen that things controller games
like 1983's X-Man which sadly was not a
wolverine sex game
[Applause]
for inspiration from classics like
Adventure where you play as a naked man
running around a maze to avoid floating
scissors and bats oh you know we all
remember that part of sex right
just me if you complete the maze you
have sex with a pixelated woman and uh
I'm not exactly sure how to censor this
[Music]
there were also games like beat him and
eat them which I can't show you
uncensored images of but um guess by the
title what it was
[Music]
James illustrate the early 1980s were
marked by a tenacity and willingness to
put sex into gaming coupled with a
general inability to do it with any
level of sensitivity these are just dots
doing the No Pants dance with other dots
at best and degrading depictions of
women at worst but dang it if we didn't
try to make it happen for better or
worse at the very least early attempts
laid bare these stumbling blocks
developers often collided with first
among them being how sex was seen as a
climax every pun intended there a reward
for beating the game sex became like
what achievement trophies are today huh
increasing gamer score almost
dissatisfying as sex even further that
reward was often sex with a woman
underscoring another Trend how the
game's protagonist was usually assumed
to be a sexually active straight dude
this dominance of men as the protagonist
of games also underscored the
predominance of Men Behind the Scenes
making games there was a lot of barriers
at the beginning of programming in
computer science they kept a lot of
women out of being able to make games
which in turn informed a lot of the
games that were being made being
targeted mostly at men all of this led
to the assumption that only straight men
played games because only games were
being made for and by straight men which
wasn't true that being said there were
some bright spots with games like
nightlife which aimed to be an aid to
sex life for couples even containing an
early version of a period tracker for
women and depictions of sexual positions
for couples to try even further though
depictions of sex often ventured into
problematic territory and one of the
most severe and notorious offenders of
this was in 1982's Custer's Revenge
where you play as General Custer and
force yourself on an indigenous woman
that you're supposedly quote unquote
saving it's a deeply dehumanizing and
awful depiction of indigenous women and
sex as a result the game gained
notoriety upon its release with many
women's rights and Indigenous groups
protesting the game and pushing
legislators to Outlaw it the game's
publisher multiple Industries even
leaned into the controversy doing things
like previewing the game for indigenous
groups before its release
[Music]
revenge is for Custer to cross over a
desert obstacle course and reach the
Indian maiden and make an impression on
her
what do you mean by impression
[Music]
yet while the protests were growing many
who took issue with the game were quick
to point out that their issue wasn't
with the showing of sex itself in a game
but with the dehumanizing depiction of
women and Indigenous people through sex
[Music]
Red Elk had gone to the duplicating
machine the print flyers by the hundreds
protesting the rape and racism of
Custer's Revenge blows this fire is
pretty strong stuff what offends you
most about the game let us suppose that
it is a Hitler character attacking a
Jewish woman would the Jewish woman be
smiling the controversy around Custer's
eventually grew to include other
sex-related games from the company like
beat him and Edom leading many to blame
Atari for the games despite Atari having
nothing to do with the creation or
publishing of the game this led to Atari
itself to respond to the controversy
with atari's consumer electronics
division President Michael Moon saying
that quote Atari takes a very dim view
of this use of our product but also
arguing that quote to say that Atari is
responsible for this occurrence would be
as illogical as censoring a camera
company for making cameras because a few
people take pornographic photographs
eventually though the pressure LED Atari
to sue the game makers leading Custer's
Revenge to be pulled but not before the
controversy had led the game to sell
over 80 000 copies twice as many as
multiple Industries next sex-based title
all of these issues that we've been
talking about as well as the taboo
nature of discussing any form of sex in
general in the United States would soon
come to a head as gaming gained more
mainstream attention
should Custer's Revenge be treated like
a book that means anything printed
anything goes or should these cartridges
be controlled and regulated like any
show you'd see on Commercial TV
well stay tuned probably the next
episode
will be shown in court
[Music]
as the gaming industry survived its
market crash in the mid 1980s and
continued to grow into the late 1980s so
too did the market for sexy video games
grow as well for example 1987 sleeper
hit Leisure Suit Larry was a direct
adaptation of soft porn Adventure in the
game you play as Larry a comically inept
man who tries to pick up young women the
game was so successful that it spawned a
cult franchise which had its most recent
entry released all the way in 2020. this
period also saw the release of games
like Cobra Mission the first Japanese
adult game to be released in the United
States yet gaming was also starting to
become more mainstream with more and
more people playing it and as a result
more attention being brought to it and
as a result that brought with it tighter
control over what could be portrayed and
sex was often the first thing censored
by the late 1980s Nintendo had dominated
and pushed the US gaming Market into the
mainstream Consciousness with its NES
console and as a result also created
content guidelines for games on the
system as they didn't want the sex-based
controversy that Atari had been and
broiled in to happen to them while
Nintendo allowed some graphic violence
nudity and sexuality were strictly
prohibited Nintendo of America went even
further heavily censoring nudity in the
American Market nest and mother 2 was
given pajamas in Her Dream sequence when
he was naked in the Japanese release
Final Fantasy VI characters were given
more clothing and lines referring to
babies and breasts and Chrono Trigger
were altered this all contrasted with
Nintendo's rival Sega which had a much
looser policy on violence and sex
despite being behind in the market Sega
sold more copies of Mortal Kombat on its
Genesis system over Nintendo because it
allowed the blood to stay in the game
leading Nintendo to let Mortal Kombat 2
do the same Sega even published Night
Trap in 1992 on the Sega CD Night Trap
was an FMV game with players trying to
save teenage girls from vampires and
featured some uh
interesting scenes
[Music]
Sega does what Nintendo indeed this
Patchwork of guidelines eventually led
to moral Panic surrounding video games
well if you look at what they represent
racism violence
pornography militarism all the worst
kinds of things in society which we
would like to eliminate so I think that
they're very detrimental this all came
to a head in 1993 when the United States
Senate held hearings on video games the
hearings led by Senators Joe Mr Peabody
Lieberman and Herb Cole focused mostly
on Mortal kombat's violence but also
night trapped sexual scenes often
forgetting to mention or straight up
mischaracterizing the game as being
about sexually terrorizing women not the
fact that the goal was actually to save
the women what is particularly troubling
about the scene
in this film that we have an extract
extract that was a graphic depiction of
the violence against women with strong
overtones of sexual violence I find this
segment deeply offensive and believe
that it simply should be taken off the
market the moral Panic surrounded the
aesthetic of sex in any form not the
nuances of issues with how it was
portrayed and it reflected the United
States as often puritanical feelings
towards sex in general all of this led
to the creation of the ESRB with the
video game industry like the motion
picture industry before it choosing to
self-regulate itself rather than having
Congress do it for them and sadly this
self-regulation had more Universal
repercussions for sex over violence
while violence could sometimes Garner a
game a t or M rating it could still be
released comparatively any explicit
depictions of sex were given the dreaded
adults only rating and console companies
like Nintendo and newcomer Sony and
Microsoft would refuse to publish AO
rated titles despite changing views on
sex within the United States there's
still a taboo nature around it in any
discussion of it and as such censorship
hasn't really gone away it's just
changed while the US government has
become less focused on censorship at
least in the video game area as are
censor dots earlier in the video
showcased even being able to talk about
sex on places like YouTube is difficult
I mean even here on this platform I've
even had to censor 3 pixels representing
genitalia like literally three dots
that's all they were that's all that
that genitalia was in Custer's Revenge
but if I say that these three dots
represent genitalia
we have to censor them if we don't this
video might get demonetized or age gated
here on YouTube
all of this shows how Market forces can
often censor videos without someone
explicitly saying to do so and this
becomes relevant for our video when we
discuss companies like Microsoft or Sony
or Nintendo and their refusal to sell
sexual based games on their console
marketplaces when it's a normal part of
an adult's experience that can be
depicted healthy safely and naturally
however by consistently making it a
taboo subject within our culture it's
given a sense of mysteriousness and
grandiosity and often becomes
misunderstood and that often leads to a
lot of our sometimes repressed views
around sex within our culture today
however even beyond that there are other
implicit biases that can influence how
sex is depicted in media and gaming
especially in the United States games
that did feature sex that were released
were often more juvenile games like Duke
Nukem or Conker's Bad Fur Day were
filled with semi-naked women or flowers
if that's your Kink she's lovely that's
why the wife kicked me out all I want to
do is pollinator
oh she's got the stoop moves like you
wouldn't believe now don't get me wrong
I am not above a good juvenile
pollination joke if you catch my um
spores but games didn't really evolve
much Beyond this for a long time there
were some games that as the medium
matured began to handle sexualized
themes with more complexity and maturity
such as the psychosexual horror game
Haunting Ground that explored how its
lead protagonist was sexualized as a
Woman by society around her using horror
tropes however even in these more
complex Stories the emphasis was still
often placed on how attractive a
stereotypically beautiful cisgender
woman was even when these games were
trying to explore deconstruct analyze or
even Empower female characters we could
even see this in games like Tomb Raider
becoming Infamous for the size of Laura
croft's some dual wielding assets if you
know what I mean and I'm not talking
about her guns Lara Croft may have rated
tombs but
she also rated my sexuality
[Music]
based on experiment
experimix narratives with gameplay
having become more standardized over
time and one element that came along
with these more complex storylines was
giving the player's agency in choosing
romanceable Partners developer BioWare
was at the Forefront of this as it added
romance options to its story focused
games like Baldur's Gate 2 and Star Wars
Knights of the Old Republic I love you
there I said it I do and I don't want
you to become a god while these romances
only typically contained Illusions to
sex within their stories they proved to
be widely popular with fans yet as
BioWare writer David Gator articulated
there was an interesting reaction to
these romanceable options from fans I
found in particular the reception for
anime uh to be the one male romance to
be quite interesting
um since he was the only one of the four
that was sort of targeted at a female
players there was a perception among a
number of the female players that was
unfair and they said like why don't we
get an equal amount of romances why did
male players get such a variety from
which to choose and and they didn't and
at the time it really seemed like
um
our only response could be that that
wasn't it was it's not about fairness
right we're developers we have uh
resources we need to allocate content is
incredibly expensive so I mean even my
response at the time was well
where we were looking at who would get
the content versus the size of the
player base I mean as far as we knew we
barely had any female fans so it seemed
you know
how awesome we were we were thought we
were being generous all of this is
because throughout gaming history in the
history of most media within Western
culture there was this underlying
assumption that Gamers were mostly men
but this also was because most people
creating games were also men themselves
and this is because of the long history
of bias towards women being able to
enter the programming and computer
science spaces and a lot of this bias
and implicit sexism ran deep throughout
the industry for example scantily clad
or not clad at all women were commonly
seen throughout gaming you even saw this
outside of games themselves but in the
real world gaming industry even look at
E3 which was meant to be a professionals
only event at the time yet was dominated
by Booth babes women hired a dress
scantily to attract attendees and sell
the games at the show what I'm
essentially describing right now is the
issue known as the male gaze many of you
have probably heard the term male gaze
and maybe even have a colloquial
definition for it to discuss how women
and others are objectified yet the
actual idea of the male gaze is a bit
more complex when we look into it it's
not just objectification alone and
that's actually the problem and the
complexity with the male gaze it's
actually about this complex relationship
between the person making the game the
person they assume is playing the game
and the game itself as well as the
actual audience that plays the game and
how all of those things treat anyone
outside of the assumed identities and
viewpoints of those the game is made for
as something alien different and other
strange or weird or something
Fantastical to look at we all play games
and watch media to have an experience
beyond our own that is different from
our everyday lives as a result if the
creators of a work of art games in this
case are mostly straight men and they
assume because of this that the audience
is primarily also straight men it leads
the game to take on the Viewpoint of
straight men as a result anyone outside
of that identity within the game gets to
be seen not just as an object but as an
other as something different from the
person presumed to be the one playing
the game and it's this otherness that is
the incredibly important factor when we
discuss the male gays who gets to be
seen as an other and whose Viewpoint
gets to be assumed to be seen as natural
and normal the Viewpoint that we take on
most of the time within media what gets
to be seen as the default Viewpoint this
then informs how the game views them and
while it's not only in sexual situations
it's most notable when it comes to sex
and desirability take for example how
the camera in Mass Effect 2 originally
lingard on Miranda's ass in some scenes
the camera wasn't a perspective shot of
your protagonist's character but the
shot was angled that way specifically to
Signal how sexy her ass was to the
presumed straight male audience who
would enjoy it thus the camera itself
took on this Viewpoint intentionally
shots like this also showcase how women
are often less shown in full shots
highlighting specific body parts
segmenting them instead of taking them
in as full people this also goes to how
characters are designed and move as well
within the game with many games
featuring women that wore tight or no
clothing and moved in a more sexually
provocative way this relationship
between the people making the game that
presume people who are viewing the game
as well as the camera itself all is what
we're talking about when we say the male
gaze further all of this affects how we
View desirability and sexual attraction
conventionally attractive women usually
white curvy and big breasted are seen as
spectacle and desirable and everyone
outside of that as seen as well frankly
less attractive it leads to this
assumption that anyone outside of this
dichotomy like lgbtq folks people of
color or women with different body types
or disabled people or numerous other
types of people are undesirable this
isn't to say women being sexy is
inherently bad as characters like
Bayonetta show you can have a character
whose sexualization is part of her story
it's not even inherently bad to view
women as sexy just for sexy's sake it
can be an end unto itself the problem
actually is the ubiquitousness of that
Viewpoint which is often centralized in
straight cisgender white men it's not
saying that that Viewpoint is inherently
a bad thing in fact you can make many
great works of art from that Viewpoint
which is why I like so many of them but
the problem is is that so much of our
art and culture treats that Viewpoint as
the default in all of our media and as a
result it becomes to be seen as the
natural and normal Viewpoint yet in
reality that Viewpoint is not the only
Viewpoint that exists by normalizing
this Viewpoint it creates an often
unconscious but still common bias that
seeing women solely as objects and
hypersexualized is not only okay but the
natural way to be instead of saying that
it's one way of many that women can be
seen and also denies women the ability
to have equal chance to possess agency
within games or more directly relevant
to our discussion on sex and gaming to
also be the ones to possess the ability
to see others in games with the same
desirability that men get to look upon
women with in most games there can be a
variety of Fun For All or choosing not
to [__] if you're asexual so slowly at
BioWare at least this implicit bias
began to be recognized and addressed
with games like Dragon Age and Mass
Effect adding more romance options
outside of the main romances for
straight male characters and there were
actual sex scenes the ones that were
Tastefully done though the romance with
male Partners often cut out before the
actual sex and many more games around
this time like heavy rain or Assassin's
Creed also began to include sex scenes
and romance options yet even this wasn't
without its problems and controversies
first and foremost Mass Effect itself
Drew criticism for many Christian and
right-wing organizations like Fox News
it's just not good and I'm definitely
not going to let uh Mass Effect in my
house another controversy kicked off
after the creation of the hot coffee mod
for Grand Theft Auto San Andreas which
let Gamers with some know-how access a
previously unaccessible sex-based
minigame that was part of the game's
code since the content was actually part
of the initial game the controversy
forced the ESRB to change the game's
rating to adults only eventually leading
again to another attempt by the United
States government this time led by
Hillary Clinton to attempt to try to
argue for federally regulating video
games today I'm announcing along with my
colleagues Senator Lieberman and bi the
family entertainment protection act this
bill will prohibit the sale of violent
and sexually explicit video games to
minors and the Federal Trade Commission
even investigated Rockstar intake to
interactive for not divulging the
content in the game but even if we move
beyond the more panics there were still
issues here the aura for example was
depicted as a monogendered species in
Mass Effect which was awesome yet
despite this Allah sorry like the art
were all represented as stereotypically
sexy Femme looking aliens so catering to
the male gaze that looks upon certain
aspects as conventionally attractive in
women though to be fair who doesn't love
Liara second only to uh Garris in his uh
sexy calibrations calibrating a giant
gun is a vacation sex was still the
culmination of your romance storylines
in all of these games with it being
treated as the end goal and reward at
the end of a romance storyline rather
than a natural part of a relationship
and something that can happen at any
point during it in real life sex can
happen on the first date or years down
the line multiple times just a few times
one time or not at all at any point
overall this era of gaming began to show
signs of growing maturity for the
industry it started to address some of
its long-standing biases yet still
perpetuated others all while dealing
with going from a niche culture to a
mainstream artistic medium
while imperfect this shift in sexual
representation had an effect as gaming
entered the 2010s and 2020s studies
showed that more women and other
marginalized folks entered gaming as
they saw more options that appeal to
them it also led to an increase in women
behind the scenes in developer roles as
well leading to more diverse games
overall but his New Perspectives began
to be represented pushed back against
this crew because the male gays had been
so normalized as the industry begins to
include more perspectives in the games
themselves than break out of that mold
some begin to feel that this means that
their identities which had previously
seemed ubiquitous were being vilified or
pushed out when you're used to seeing
something only one way New Perspectives
can sometimes appear like oppression or
antagonism yet this isn't the case we
still have many male protagonists and
still enjoy playing as them but just
wish to include more voices in the
creation of and in the games themselves
yet this has led to some unacceptable
pushback for example some fans barked at
the less sexualized appearance of
characters like Horizon for Ben West
alloy or the more robust body type of
Thor in God of War Ragnarok just because
someone is bigger doesn't mean they
aren't healthy or fit and even if they
weren't that doesn't mean that they
shouldn't be represented and also who
doesn't love fat Thor he's fat Thor we
love fat Thor Here We Stand fat Thor
here sadly too these outdated viewpoints
are still sometimes reflected in game
development spaces as well for example
ubisoft's Assassin's Creed Odyssey was
going to have the female Cassandra be
the only playable lead but ubisoft's
marketing team and creative lead sadly
wouldn't allow it saying women don't
sell games and all of this is sometimes
caused by many cisgender men feeling
like they're being vilified for wanting
to be in a gaming space
that's certainly and sadly often The
Narrative that some will take away when
watching videos like this one where
someone like myself a trans woman or
anyone else especially from someone
whose viewpoints don't often get shown
in media try to talk about these issues
but I and many of us are not here to say
men are bad but we're trying to say that
the anxieties surrounding expanding
diversity often get weaponized for
darker ends and that we need to have
better education and discussions
surrounding these issues and also more
importantly less adversarial
conversations this isn't about me versus
you it's about all of us coming together
to have a welcoming discussion about
these issues kind of like what I'm
hoping this video will be
all of this may seem off topic to
discussing the act of sex and games but
it's important context that's because
while these issues are prevalent the
increase in diversity in all areas of
gaming has led to Great developments in
the showcasing of sex in gaming itself
games like The Last of Us Part 2 have
featured lesbian protagonists for
example further similarly Last of Us
Part 2 showcases how many games don't
feature sex as the end goal of a story
but as part of it while also
simultaneously showing women of
different body types like Abby's more
muscular build to also have sex scenes
we're also seeing more representation of
asexual people such as in the outer
worlds games have also begun to feature
more complex discussions of issues
surrounding sex like boyfriend dungeons
discussion of stalking and abuse no more
pollination jokes though I'm still here
for those and while there's still no
shortage of hot and sexy ladies men are
also getting in on the sexy Times Like
The Witcher 3 geralt Infamous bathing
scene which allowed men to show a
different side of them cells and also be
sexualized it's all about finding a
balance allowing identities to slip
between the desire or holder of the Gaze
and the desired the one gazed upon
instead of it only being in one
direction from one certain type of
viewpoint with women always being seen
as the objects of desire in that
situation and we're getting better at
depicting that
and there's still so much left to
explore I mean we didn't even talk about
virtual reality and how people have
found sex in those spaces alone and with
others oh yeah that is perfect
uh
I swear I'm not looking at anything
inappropriate in this thing
well things like consent or depictions
of sex workers in gaming we also didn't
talk about things that only games allow
us to do like play with our identity so
I hope you're open to the conversation
as we continue talking about sex and
video games both on this channel and in
other places as we attempt to go into
the covers and see how gaming today can
continue to improve and grow just like
it's always done since its Inception
but speak of the future I've got to
return to my um
let's just call it Half-Life Alex
gameplay yeah we'll go with that so
until next time
[Music]